All good things must come to an end,
but some good things come to an end
more than once. These TV shows ended up
on the chopping block multiple times.
"Taxi" premiered on ABC all the way back in 1978,
featuring a cast of current and future
stars of the late '70s and early '80s as
a collective of New York City taxi drivers.
The show starred the likes of Judd Hirsch,
Danny DeVito, Christopher Lloyd, Tony Danza,
Marilu Henner, and Andy Kaufman. In hindsight,
the show seemed too big to fail, and in
reality, it actually was too big to fail.
"Taxi" ran for four seasons until 1982,
racking up Emmy wins and nominations and
becoming one of ABC's biggest commercial
successes. It seems ludicrous that ABC
would ever cancel the program, which
was a sentiment echoed at the time,
with creator James L. Brooks
telling The Washington Post,
"The one thing that's clear from this is
that the network is saying to everybody,
'Don't think Emmys will do you any
good when it comes to scheduling.'"
After HBO declined to pick up the series, NBC came
to the rescue, restoring "Taxi" to its original
time slot of Thursday nights following their hit
sitcom "Cheers." Sadly, the ratings failed to live
up to NBC's expectations, resulting in its second
cancellation after only one additional season in
1983. However, most of the cast got to briefly
reunite to film re-enactments of "Taxi" scenes
with Jim Carrey when the comedian starred in the
1999 biopic "Man on the Moon" as Andy Kaufman.
Most television audiences became aware of
"Cagney & Lacey" as a police procedural that
aired from 1982 to 1988 on CBS starring
Sharon Gless and Tyne Daly as detectives
juggling their complex personal lives with
crime-solving in New York City. However,
most people only know its resurrected
state. It originally debuted as a pilot
in 1981 starring Loretta Swit in
the role of Cagney alongside Daly,
while Meg Foster took over the role when it was
ordered to a six-episode first season in 1982.
Following the show's first season,
CBS pulled it from their lineup,
citing poor ratings and audiences not connecting
with the two characters' aggression. This
decision by the network resulted in backlash from
audiences, while the show's executive producer,
Barney Rosenzweig, tried to re-negotiate to get
the show put back on the air. Their compromise was
to recast Foster with Sharon Gless, who was
previously the first choice to play Cagney.
The second season premiered to a rocky start,
with the show getting canceled for a second
time in 1983, but fan outcry eventually
got it picked up for a third season,
which saw it receive a boost in the ratings. Gless
and Daly proved to be a dynamic onscreen duo,
resulting in the show lasting another four seasons
before CBS canceled it for good in 1988 after a
ratings decline, leaving its Season 7 cliffhanger
unresolved. Although a rebooted pilot in 2018
couldn't get off the ground at CBS, the show
did see four TV movies since its cancellation.
"What? That's bogus, man. This is public
property, you can't tell us where to surf."
"Wrong, pal! You endangered lives.
It's my call. You're outta here."
It's hard to believe that a show like
"Baywatch," which continues to hold the
record for the largest TV audience of all time,
ever struggled to grab the attention of audiences.
Premiering on NBC in 1989, the show starred
an ensemble cast featuring David Hasselhoff
and Pamela Anderson, who would go on to become
some of the biggest celebrities of the 1990s.
However, after its first season aired, NBC quickly
put it to bed due to poor ratings and reviews.
However, its reruns in countries like Germany and
the U.K. saved the show, as broadcasting company
LBS Communications revived "Baywatch" in 1991.
"Baywatch" continued to air in its original form
for 10 additional seasons throughout the '90s.
After its ninth season in 1999, the show was
restructured, recast, relocated to Hawaii, and
rebranded as "Baywatch: Hawaii" to save costs.
As one would expect, the massive overhaul
of "Baywatch: Hawaii" didn't sit well with
audiences at the time, with the show facing a
steep decline in ratings until it was canceled
in 2001 after 11 seasons. However, the "Baywatch"
brand has lived on through spin-off series,
a 2003 film, as well as a 2017 film
starring Dwayne Johnson, Zac Efron,
and Alexandra Daddario that was
panned by reviewers for many of
the same reasons the original "Baywatch"
series never garnered critical acclaim.
"The truth is out there, but so are lies."
"The X-Files" was a game-changer
for science-fiction television,
becoming one of the first shows of the 1990s to
gain a cult fanbase through the early internet.
Starring David Duchovny and Gillian Anderson as
FBI agents investigating paranormal occurrences,
"The X-Files" premiered on Fox in 1993 and
quickly rose to become the cult phenomenon
that it currently is. However, the show didn't
maintain its well-deserved praise forever.
The ninth season of "The X-Files," which aired
between 2001 and 2002, was victim to a drop in
ratings and poor reviews from television critics,
who cited the series' lackluster writing compared
to its earlier, more inspired seasons. Fox
pulled the plug on the series, though its creator
Chris Carter blamed the series' cancelation on
audiences' unwillingness to watch a show about
conspiracies and corruption in the wake of the
September 11 terrorist attacks, telling Gizmodo,
"There was lots more we could have
done but we ended at the right time."
To the delight of many hardcore fans, Fox
gave "The X-Files" a second chance in 2016,
reviving it for a 10th season with
Duchovny and Anderson returning. The
two actors also returned for an 11th
season, but following its conclusion,
Anderson officially parted ways with the show.
This brought the series to a premature end for
a second time as the creators currently have no
intention to continue on without Dana Scully.
"7th Heaven" was a late hit of the 1990s,
premiering in 1996. The series, which centers
on a Protestant family living in California with
seven kids of varying ages, quickly became a
hit on The WB network. However, the series was
subject to network shake-ups in 2006 after The
WB was shut down during a merger with the United
Paramount Network to form a new channel: The CW.
During the change, The WB canceled "7th Heaven"
after 10 seasons, mostly due to the series' high
production costs and dwindling ratings compared
to The WB's other series like "Gilmore Girls"
and "Smallville." Additionally, some of the
show's biggest stars, such as Jessica Biel and
Barry Watson, had left the show in its later
seasons and were unlikely to return. However,
once the ratings spiked following the announcement
of the show's ending, The CW made the surprising
decision to pick "7th Heaven" back up for
an 11th season to seize on the opportunity.
Sadly, this decision didn't last long
at The CW. The series was once again
canceled by the network in 2007 after
the end of the season. Even the show's
cast members have shot down recent
queries about a possible revival as
recently as 2023 due to controversies
amongst some of the other cast members.
Matt Groening is best known as the
co-creator of "The Simpsons," the
simultaneous longest-running animated series
and American sitcom on television. However,
he also garnered a cult fanbase
for his second animated series,
"Futurama," which premiered in 1999 on Fox.
"Futurama" centers on Philip J. Fry, a pizza
delivery man who is mistakenly cryogenically
frozen and reawakens 1,000 years later, where
he's hired by an intergalactic delivery company
alongside an eccentric ensemble of characters.
Compared to "The Simpsons," the life span of
"Futurama" on Fox was short-lived due to its
inconsistent airtime, resulting
in its cancellation in 2002.
"Yes, I'm afraid the brainless drones who
run the network canceled our license."
It wasn't until years later, after the show
had gained a second life through syndicated
reruns and four direct-to-video movies, that
"Futurama" was picked up for its fifth season
by Comedy Central, who continued to air it for
an additional two seasons after that. However,
the show was never on solid ground on
Comedy Central, producing several possible
series finales until 2013, when its actual
finale, "Meanwhile," aired on the network.
Until recently, "Futurama" was thought to be
long dead, but the impossible happened in 2022
when Hulu ordered a revival of the series
to air on their streaming service. However,
this revival news came with controversy after
voice actor John DiMaggio threatened to not
reprise his role as Bender without a pay raise for
the entire cast. Fortunately, once a new deal was
worked out, DiMaggio did end up returning.
Hopefully this time, it doesn't go away.
"Family Guy" was the brainchild
of voice actor Seth MacFarlane,
centering on the Rhode Island-based Griffin
family and their various antics. Its first
season was subject to good ratings in 1999, but
when its second season saw a decline in 2000,
Fox abruptly canceled the show, only to revive
it for a third season a few months later.
Once "Family Guy" struggled to maintain
high ratings for its third season,
Fox canceled it yet again in 2002 and sold
the rights to Cartoon Network, who began
airing reruns of the program on their late-night
Adult Swim programming block. It slowly gained
more attention from Adult Swim's audiences,
and thanks to the additional sales of DVDs,
"Family Guy" was revived by Fox for
a second time in 2004. Thankfully,
MacFarlane kept an optimistic outlook about the
show's ups and downs, telling the Calgary Sun,
"We really wanted to keep
the show exactly as it was."
Since its fourth season return in 2005,
"Family Guy" has remained a staple of the
Fox network and a consistent success. As of 2023,
"Family Guy" has aired a total of 21 seasons,
and MacFarlane has remained a
part of the show's voice cast.
Debuting on ABC in 2001, "Scrubs" starred Zach
Braff as J.D., the daydreaming medical intern
at Sacred Heart Hospital, who pines
for his fellow intern Elliot Reid,
played by Sarah Chalke. The show's early
seasons were beloved by critics and fans alike,
with Entertainment Weekly saying of it in 2006,
"A likable, daffy, buoyant series
that would be a big annoying mess
if it weren't done just right, Scrubs
is the very definition of nimble."
However, "Scrubs" hit a brick wall when the
Writers' Guild of America went on strike from
2007 to 2008, short-changing its seventh
season by seven episodes and ultimately
dooming it to cancellation due to production
being stalled. After a period of not knowing
if "Scrubs" would continue airing, ABC picked
the show up for its eighth season. While this
would be seen as a victory by some, it
would soon become bittersweet when it was
announced that Braff intended to depart from
the show's main cast at the end of the season.
"Sometimes when you get what you want,
you end up missing what you left behind."
"Scrubs" returned for its ninth season in 2009,
featuring a predominantly new cast of medical
students at Winston University. Though Braff
appeared in six of the season's 13 episodes,
fans were adamantly opposed to the vast
changes in the show's formula. Eventually,
ABC announced that "Scrubs" was canceled in
2010, with Braff telling his Facebook followers,
"It was worth a try, but alas... it didn't work."
Thankfully, the world of Internet meme culture
has kept "Arrested Development" alive longer
than any network could. Created by Mitch Hurwitz,
"Arrested Development" premiered on Fox in 2003,
led by Jason Bateman's Michael Bluth, the
son of a corrupt real estate developer who
struggles to keep his family of narcissistic,
delusional, and financially struggling socialites
together. The show boasted one of the strongest
ensembles in TV history, including David Cross,
Will Arnett, and Jessica Walter, as well as
up-and-comers Alia Shawkat and Michael Cera.
After three seasons of low ratings on Fox,
"Arrested Development" was canceled by the
network, but Hurwitz was determined
to find a second home for the series.
"I don't think the Home Builder's
Organization is going to be supporting us."
"Yeah, the HBO is not gonna
want us. What do we do now?"
"Well, I think it's Showtime."
After years of failed starts and rumors of
a film, "Arrested Development" was finally
revived by Netflix, which aired a fourth season in
2013 featuring the entire returning cast. However,
due to the conflicting schedules of the show's
cast, the season was structured to make each
episode focused on an individual character, with
plotlines intersecting throughout the episodes.
"Arrested Development" remained dormant for many
more years after the divisive fourth season. It
wasn't until 2018 that the show finally returned
for the first half of its fifth season, with
a second half released in 2019. By this point,
tensions off-screen became tiresome for the cast,
including an incident of Jeffrey Tambor's
abusive on-set behavior. That, mixed with the
unfortunate passing of Walter in 2021, means that
"Arrested Development" is probably gone for good.
"The show's gonna last three weeks!"
"Six seasons and a movie!"
Although "Community" captured a dedicated
fanbase from its very first episode,
behind the scenes the show struggled to stay
on the air. The NBC sitcom premiered in 2009,
starring Joel McHale as an ex-lawyer
forced to attend community college,
where he befriends a study group of misfits and
outcasts in an ensemble including Gillian Jacobs,
Alison Brie, Donald Glover, and Chevy
Chase. The show was created by future
"Rick & Morty" co-creator Dan Harmon, who was the
main catalyst for the show's off-screen troubles.
After a public feud with Chase over disagreements
with the show's direction, Harmon was fired from
season four of "Community," only to be rehired
after Chase himself left the show. Harmon returned
for season five of "Community," but by that point
it was too little too late, and "Community" found
itself on NBC's chopping block in 2014. However,
after adopting the tagline "Six seasons and a
movie" from a previous episode, fans were
determined to find the sitcom a new home.
"Community" found its saving grace in Yahoo!
Screen, which ordered a sixth season of the show,
though by this point both Glover and Yvette
Nicole Brown had departed from the cast,
with others eyeing their post-"Community" futures.
Although some involved insisted that "Community"
was not canceled, Yahoo! Screen shut down in
2016, canning the series' future. To the delight
of all "Community" fans, the long-awaited movie
was finally confirmed in 2022 to be happening.
"Cougar Town" marked a triumphant return to
the sitcom format for Courteney Cox, who rose
to fame by playing Monica on NBC's "Friends" from
1994 to 2004. On "Cougar Town," Cox plays Jules,
a recent divorcée re-exploring dating in her
40s, with an ensemble of her friends played
by Dan Byrd, Busy Philipps, and Christa
Miller. The show premiered on ABC in 2009,
though faced many setbacks in its run,
including producers requesting a name change.
Its biggest setback, however, came after the third
season, when ABC removed it from their mid-season
schedule, priming the producers for a potential
cancellation. These predictions came to fruition,
but "Cougar Town" was thankfully saved by TBS,
who picked it up for a fourth season in 2013,
and then subsequently renewed
it for a fifth and sixth season.
"I honestly thought we might never be
in this kitchen again. Just hanging out,
telling our stories to each other. To the world."
Sadly for fans of the single-camera sitcom, TBS
opted to end its renewals after the sixth season,
rendering that the final season of "Cougar
Town" after it finished airing in 2015.
Though the show was more prepared
than most for its series finale,
that doesn't mean the cast wasn't
disappointed that the show wouldn't
continue on TBS. As Josh Hopkins, who
played Grayson in the show, told Variety,
"I'm going to miss seeing those people every day,
but I just think what a great experience
it was, rather than be sad that it's over."
"Nashville" premiered on ABC in 2012, centering
on Hayden Panettiere as a rising country star
named Juliette Barnes who threatens the
power of Connie Britton's Rayna James.
The biggest draw to "Nashville," naturally,
was its music. The show included original
songs and covers that were distributed by
Big Machine Records, the same Nashville
label that formerly supported Taylor Swift's
rise to country stardom in the early 2000s.
Sadly, "Nashville" was abruptly canceled by
ABC after its fourth season. The announcement
came shortly after ABC confirmed that the
show would be heralded by new showrunners,
which meant that it would be renewed for a
fifth season. However, the renewal didn't
come very quickly, so the show's fans resorted
to an online campaign to bring the show back to
life after many were disappointed at where
the fourth season left the series off. The
show was revived on the CMT network in 2016,
a more than appropriate home for the show.
Season five of "Nashville" premiered in 2016,
but fans were even more shocked by the series'
turn of events, which saw Connie Britton's
character killed off in the first half of
the season. Though the show was renewed for
a final sixth season which aired in 2018,
CMT opted to not keep it going beyond that point.
The future seemed hopeful for "Designated
Survivor" when it began. Starring Kiefer
Sutherland as a man designated as
next-in-line for the U.S. presidency
after a terrorist attack kills everybody
ahead of him in the line of succession,
the show premiered in 2016 on ABC with
lots of network support behind it.
Rather than have a pilot ordered
like most shows typically do,
"Designated Survivor" was
ordered straight to series,
and was renewed for a second season within
a week of its first season finale airing.
However, in a business decision almost
as jarring as the show's initial order,
ABC abruptly canceled "Designated Survivor" in
2018 after a high turnover of showrunners and
difficult production scheduling failed
to meet the network's expectations.
However, Netflix opted to renew the
show for a third season themselves,
as they had already handled the distribution of
"Designated Survivor" to international markets.
Following its third season, Netflix
ultimately made the decision to not
renew "Designated Survivor" any further,
with the company thanking Sutherland and
the crew for creating a satisfying
final season. Designated Survivor"
wasn't lucky enough to be revived beyond
the second chance that Netflix gave it.
"Well, I really screwed that up, didn't I?"
However, most fans of the series are
more than satisfied with how it ended.
As far as network science fiction television shows
go, "Timeless" had quite an interesting premise,
focusing on a trio traveling through time to stop
a terrorist organization from altering historical
events. "Timeless" was eventually canceled by
the network after the end of its first season.
"Timeless" sadly suffered from poor ratings
during its run on NBC. Fans clamored for the
show to be revived by another network, but
to the surprise of the series' creators,
"Timeless" was renewed three
days later by NBC themselves,
albeit with a downsized episode order at only 10
episodes. However, this revival didn't last long,
as NBC canceled the show yet again in
2018 after the second season ended.
This time around, "Timeless" fans
didn't have to wait too long to
see the series properly conclude.
In their second change of mind,
NBC ordered a two-part finale to wrap up the
series, airing as a Christmas special in 2018
and featuring the time-traveling trio rewinding
to the Hungnam evacuation during the Korean War,
which occurred during Christmas 1950.
Thankfully, this two-part finale was
more than enough for fans to say goodbye to the
series that ran longer than NBC wanted it to.